in this video we'll discuss account hold
and how to communicate this account
status with your user a subscription
begins account hold when a user's form
of payment fails and grace period has
ended you should block access to your
content or service while a user is in
account hold users will automatically
receive access again when the payment
method is fixed this can encourage users
to update their payment method without
cancelling their subscription which can
lead to greater user retention if a user
has multiple subscriptions in account
hold due to an issue with the same
payment method for example an expired
credit card then fixing that payment
method once will restore all of the
subscriptions for all of the users apps
connected to that particular payment
method apps that do not enable account
hold cannot be automatically restored
when a user fixes their payment we
recommend enabling both grace period and
account hold account hold will begin
after the grace period has ended to
activate account hold sign in to your
play console and select your app on the
Left menu click store presents in app
products select a subscriptions tab and
expand a subscription settings section
then check the activate account hold
check box with real-time developer
notifications you'll receive a
notification when a subscription enters
account hold call the Google Play
Developer API from your server to record
the new subscription information
you should then provide a message in
your app that tells the user that there
is a problem with their payment
information be sure to include a deep
link to the Google Play subscription
center so the user can fix their payment
method for more information on setting
up deep links visit the link on screen
it's important to note that if users
expect your app to perform services
outside the app such as sending your
user a notification for stock market
alerts or notifying them when their
favorite team is playing you may want to
send a push notification or an email to
the user to let them know that their
service is no longer active but if your
services are contained within your app
it might be okay to wait until the next
time they open the app before informing
them of the issue
for more information visit the link on
screen or check out our other videos